you get a lot of people who run
businesses quite big businesses
sometimes who are basically still just
recruiters even if they're not doing
recruitment on a day-to-day basis their
mentality is recruitment in one of those
seven characteristics of a scalability
mentality and Leadership mentality is
this ability to not feel guilty when
you're not on the tools when you're not
working in your business you're working
on new business so do you're building
plans you're executing the plans you're
feeding yourself with new ideas
shouldn't feel guilty about that in the
same way that you shouldn't feel guilty
about taking holidays they're necessary
business Investments and if all you do
is work in your business that's all
you'll ever do the more you work on your
business today the less you work in your
business tomorrow